Irán seguirá protestando la supuesta
abolición de la policía de la moral
anunciada el fin de semana por el fiscal
general
montaceri no ha calmado la revuelta
Popular la rama judicial no es la
competente para ordenar este tipo de
decisiones y el presidente iraní ebrahim
Racing no ha confirmado la eliminación
de este órgano policial todo lo
contrario medios locales reportan que
hay un aumento de los patrulleros de la
moral sobre todo en las ciudades más
religiosas en entrevista con France 24
Marta González periodista especialista
en Oriente medio dijo que la percepción
internacional sobre posibles reformas
del régimen iraní no corresponde con la
realidad pues lo que estamos viendo Es
una continuación
de la radicalización del régimen hay
cerca de 450 muertos y son
los sectores precisamente más dinámicos
más aperturistas Más progresistas sin
embargo los manifestantes iraníes exigen
un cambio y confían en que lo habrá
el régimen iraní sabe muy bien que vive
sus últimos días está a punto de caer el
régimen hace todo lo que se pueda para
sobrevivir más tiempo y sabe muy bien
Que si mantiene la obligación de portar
el velo está destinado a desaparecer
al descontento popular se sumaron los
comerciantes y Los camioneros y
respondieron al llamado general de
huelga en casi 40 ciudades Los hombres
también se ven afectados por las
drásticas restricciones de la policía de
la moral y el régimen de los ayatolas
pero las mujeres son las más castigadas
la muerte de maxa Mini fue solo un
ejemplo de violencia a pesar de que la
policía de la moral no puede juzgar y
solo se limita a avisar a las
autoridades competentes sobre el
incumplimiento del Código de vestimenta
islámico casos como el de la joven kurda
Max a mini cuestionan el verdadero papel
de los patrulleros de la moral